[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
four former minneapolis police officers
now indicted by a federal grand jury for
george floyd's death
why seven people are now facing charges
after investigators say
a mummified body was found in a home
wrapped in christmas lights
the alleged cult and their apparent
leader now dead and
the colorado mother missing mother's day
last year her husband
now charge in her murder plus testimony
continues in the ohio trial
of a man accused of murdering his
roommate burning the dismembered remains
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
a federal grand jury has indicted four
former minneapolis police officers
in the death of george floyd angela levy
is here to explain what these civil
rights charges mean
yeah brian this is the federal
indictment charging the four
officers including derek chovin in
george floyd's death
all of the officers are charged with
violating floyd's
rights under the color of law
i cannot breathe i cannot breathe
federal prosecutors allege what happened
to george floyd last year
in police custody was a violation of his
civil rights
specifically the grand jury found that
chauvin placing his left knee on floyd's
neck
and right knee on floyd's arm and back
until he became unresponsive and died
violated the law two tau and alexander
king are accused of willfully failing to
intervene
when they knew floyd was unresponsive
and didn't stop chauvin's unreasonable
use of
force a third count accuses chauvin tal
king and thomas lane of deliberate
indifference to floyd's serious medical
needs
former u.s attorney ben glassman
explains the charges
deprivation of rights under color of law
means that you are
violating somebody else's constitutional
rights
and that you are doing so while you are
acting with the authority of the state
chauvin faces two additional charges of
deprivation of rights under the color of
law
for a 2017 incident involving a 14 year
old boy
prosecutors write that chauvin held the
juvenile by the throat and struck him in
the head with a flashlight several times
the teen lost consciousness the second
count involves an
allegation that chauvin placed his knee
on the teen's neck and back
when he was handcuffed and not resisting
this indicates to me that
the fbi did a very thorough
investigation and
was able to generate evidence sufficient
to charge
for this uh previously unknown incident
uh that chovin is also now accused of
jonathan mcclellan heads the minnesota
justice coalition and had written a
letter asking the doj
for a patterns and practices
investigation
it is overdue um i'm happy that the
the the charges um and and uh my
organization supports the charges
um that have been levied against chavin
and
his accomplices
and ben glassman told me that the
charges that have been filed against
these officers are actually eligible for
the death penalty but he says it's clear
from looking at that indictment that the
department of justice
chose not to pursue the death penalty in
this case
brian thanks again joining us today is
legal analyst dina dahl and terry austin
dina willfully failing to intervene and
deliver indifference to medical
conditions
your thoughts on the charges for the
three officers awaiting a state trial
and the timing of it all
i think that these charges were very
reasonable and they're likely to stick
because
that they didn't have overt acts they
did have this
deliberate indifference and so i think
it will be fairly easy for the
prosecution to prove
the fact that it's coming before the
state means that
if the prosecutors cannot convince the
jury of this
the state will get a chance to see what
worked and what did not work at the
trial and that will be
hugely helpful to them when they bring
their own case i can see however
these defendants wanting to do a plea
bargain
especially in the state case when we
know now they're faced with
this federal maybe around the time of
the sentencing of chauvin either
soon before or soon after we may see a
plea bargain in the state case for these
defendants
yeah we'll see if the prosecution will
extend that their trial is coming up
uh this summer terry appealing a murder
conviction tax charges
and now federal charges that include
acts of uh
putting a knee on someone's neck and
hitting a teen over the head with a
flashlight
2021 does not look like it's going well
for chauvin what are your thoughts
brian there's no question he is going to
be dealing with these legal cases for
quite some time you know the state
criminal conviction was
a complete victory was on all three
counts and
that absolutely meant that it was
overwhelming evidence which i think
helped to lead the doj to actually bring
their case against him they mentioned
the state criminal case when they
brought the indictment and you know it
states that he
willfully deprived george floyd of his
constitutional rights
and that related to an unreasonable
seizure
and including unreasonable force so they
are making sure just like the state did
that this individual is being held
responsible
for his own personal actions and i think
that's going to go
far as the future is concerned and other
police officers
being held accountable for their
individual actions as well
you can see the adjustment in the
language and the doj's paperwork where
they're saying that sherwin's knee was
on
george floyd's neck and back not like
they did in the state making it very
specific and very pointed
and jeanette what's next after the
indictment
well the three other officers thomas
lane alex king
and two tao they already made their
initial appearances
and were released on an appearance bond
that happened via zoom um derek shovin
will
obviously have to make his initial
appearance he is being held in a state
prison
a very secure state prison in minnesota
and so obviously there will be a
discovery process that will have to take
place
um with the feds but a lot of that
they already know a lot of that
information based on the state case so
there will be some discussions i'm sure
back and forth between the attorneys
and the department of justice in this
case and we want to tell you that we've
got a lot more on this
this has been a trial that's captivated
everyone's attention and we are going to
be taking a deep dive into it all
weekend long
on the law and crime network we are
going to have a special called law and
crime presents
inside the derek chauvin trial we'll
have all of the key testimony the things
that could have impacted the trial from
the outside
exclusive legal analysis and we are also
going to have a discussion
about these new federal civil rights
charges which we were all anticipating
would take place we had heard that a
grand jury had been convened
even before the state trial for derrick
chauvin took place
brian thanks angenet and for more on
what's going on at the law and crime
network
let's check in with the hosts of the
show prime crime jesse weber
hey there brian yeah we're discussing
anthony kirkland a brutal serial killer
out of ohio
and what's really chilling about this
case is that it started with a missing
teenager
but ended with multiple dead bodies like
so many of the subjects we cover it's
the killer himself who walks us through
these deaths
what made you kill him what maybe would
do whatever you did
[Music]
yeah kirkland's legal journey is not
straightforward there is a surprising
twist
to find out what happens tune in to long
crime
thanks jesse still ahead on law and
crime daily love has one takes a bizarre
twist
as members of the spiritual group are
now under arrest but first
when will a former florida deputy
accused of planting drugs on the job
stand trial
the shocking body cam video on the other
side of this break
[Music]
welcome back a former florida sheriff's
deputy accused of planting drugs on
unsuspecting motorists is set to stand
trial this monday
zachary wester is facing 67 charges
including
racketeering official misconduct
fabricating evidence and false
imprisonment
an investigation into wester began in
august of 2018
when the jackson county sheriff's office
asked state officials to look into one
of their own
prosecutors say body cam video captured
the deputy putting white packets
containing meth
during traffic stops
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
it is yogurt i know okay
how about this so that is not mine no
sir okay i'm not going to ask you no sir
i'm not going to ask you any direct
questions i'm going to read you your
rights first okay so just hang out with
deputy hayek here
300 of wester's cases have been reviewed
charges in nearly 120 of them have been
dropped
12 victims are set to take the stand
against wester
south carolina lawmakers are looking to
bring out the firing squad
literally lawmakers in the palmetto
state say they face an insufficient
supply
of the drugs used for lethal injection
and have to look for other options
seven inmates are in line to be executed
and if lethal injection
isn't available a new bill will give the
inmates a choice
between the electoral chair and a firing
squad the bill is approved in march by
the state
senate and was voted by the house this
week it faces a routine final vote in
the house
before it lands on the governor's desk
for approval
seven members of the spiritual group
love has one have been arrested in
colorado
authorities say the body of the group's
leader amy carlson was found mummified
inside a sleeping bag at a home in
creston
according to a sergeant searching the
home the remains were decorated with
christmas tree lights and set up in
quote
some kind of a shrine with glitter
makeup on the body's eyes
the man who tipped off authorities
reportedly believes members drove the
body from california to colorado
the sheriff's office says they have
received complaints from families
claiming the group is brainwashing
people
and stealing their money investigators
also found a two-year-old boy
and 13-year-old girl sleeping in the
home the seven people are facing charges
of abuse of a corpse and two counts of
child abuse
back with us as legal analyst dina dahl
and terry austin terry
abuse of a corpse in child abuse are the
only charges so far
but an autopsy hasn't come in yet should
we be expecting an upgrade in charges
when it does
absolutely brian there's no question i
think what the authorities were trying
to do here
is to make sure they had enough probable
cause to support
the charges that they have and the
charges that they have right now
are the abuse of the corpse and the fact
that you know they
may have molested these children but or
you know not taking good care of them
but in a sense it does remind me of the
lori and chad day bill case because
you're going to bring the charges you
can support until you get more evidence
and once they have a corpse and an
autopsy they're going to be able to
determine
the manner and cause of death once the
autopsy comes back and then they'll be
able to say
that this is what the event was and this
is what caused the death and this
is why we can bring these murder charges
so hopefully that will happen here
yeah we'll make sure to check out the
cause and also other aspects on our
medical examiner's report
now you came up with this idea that
could it be
possible for the religious group to
argue under the first amendment some
sort of
religious freedom uh for the charges
like abuse of a corpse or others
because it doesn't really seem like they
were abusing her corpse more like
honoring their leader
yes exactly and under the law in
california their abuse of corpse is that
it
it's outrageous to normal family
sensibilities
but you do have an intersection there of
freedom of religion because what is okay
maybe for one religion would not be for
another
it does seem here with the the lights
and the
uh glitter that they were either
worshiping her or trying to
honor her whether or not that can
legally stick
we could assume if they did not actually
kill her but this is on trial
that we will see this argument that they
did it
not for the purposes of abusing her but
honoring her in some way so even if
legally they can't make the freedom of
religion work
it still might be persuasive to some of
the jurors makes sense some people get
cremated some people get
buried underground some people put their
bodies out to the ocean so
maybe this is for their religion that
nice idea
we'll see how it works out coming up on
law and crime daily an ohio detective
takes the stand
in the case of the dismembered roommate
plus a mother's day tragedy
the mother reported missing in colorado
on mother's day 2020
why her husband is now behind bars next
we're back the husband of a missing
colorado mother has now been charged
with her murder
49 year old mother of two suzanne murphy
was reported missing by her neighbor on
mother's day
2020. just seven days later her husband
barry morphy
took to social media pleading for her
safe return
please we'll do whatever it takes to
bring you back
we love you we miss you your girls need
you
no questions asked however much they
want
i will do whatever it takes to get you
back honey i love you
but after searching for nearly a year
including 135 search warrants
and more than 400 interviews
investigators now believe her husband
is responsible for her disappearance
barry morphy was arrested this week on
charges
of first-degree murder evidence
tampering and attempting to influence a
public servant
here to discuss the missing mom of
mother's day is legal analyst dina dahl
and terry austin terry what are your
thoughts about the uh heartfelt plea
from barry morphew
uh that's definitely coming to trial do
you think he's a criminal mastermind or
a loving husband and father
you know i think depending on the
evidence they have i think the jury is
going to think he's a criminal
mastermind and not a loving father
anytime you
have family members or someone who was
the last person to see someone
obviously that individual is a suspect
and the jury knows that they're thinking
about that case
and clearly if he was represented by an
attorney at that point which it doesn't
sound like he was
he would not have gone on to social
media to plead his case and that will be
introduced into evidence
and it'll give the jury an opportunity
to decipher
is he telling the truth why is he doing
this and it could very well be used
against him
now dean i can see this taking quite
some time to get to trial and be a
massive trial 135 search warrants and
400 interviews across
multiple states what do you think the
prosecution's gonna look like in this
case
so far they have revealed very little
information and
so we don't know that many details i'm
hoping because they don't have a body
here that although they were far and
wide and they're collecting of evidence
that they are
very narrow and specific in their scope
because without
a body they're going to just have
circumstantial evidence and they can
confuse
the jury but it sounds like the sister
of the victim
already believes that he is guilty she
said she's in fact
already forgiven him so you know that's
not a good sign
that she might know kind of more than we
do at this point and there may be some
very strong evidence against him
they just really have to reel it in and
keep it very specific
it's definitely gonna be a lot of
information we'll see how the defense
handles that when the trial comes up
when we come back prosecutors claim an
ohio man dismembered and burned his
roommate
what the investigating detective reveals
on the stand on the other side of the
break
welcome back graphic testimony is
underway in the ohio trial of a man
accused of killing his roommate
and burning his body to hide the
evidence
michael dixon is on trial for murdering
dismembering and then burning the
remains of his roommate
jim whitaker the 41 year old dixon
admitted to killing
but claims it was self-defense
prosecutors say
it was murder one of the investigative
detectives says
dixon led them to the remains after
confessing
that is mr dixon pointing to the burn
pit
the area that he felt that mr whitaker
was located in
mr dixon talked in his interviews the
shot shell that he used to kill mr
whitaker
it was in a clear case a clear shell
this was a clear shell that we found
that was discharged
in the basement this is a chainsaw blade
that we recovered in the burn pit as
well
and it looks like it was burnt in the
burn pit
from the anthropologists we found out
that
the bones that we recovered of mr
whitaker's
it had sharp cuts from a sharp
instrument
but that also had other edges that would
be
consistent with being cut up with a
chainsaw blade
these are the bones the anthropologists
pointed out
hey these are probably most likely human
bones and we went back on a search
warrant and collected these bones
on cross-examination the defense asked
the detective if investigators would
have ever found the remains if not for
their client
but when you mentioned on the stand
earlier you said that you wouldn't even
thought
to look in the burn pile until he told
you is that accurate
that is inaccurate we actually searched
that area by
cadaver dog earlier that week so that
area was searched
okay but you ended up doing a thorough
search where you started
excavating after he told you to look
there correct that is correct
okay and when he told you to look there
you eventually found some of the remains
correct
that is correct so that would be a
consistent statement that he made
correct
that was a statement made true saying
that jimmy was in there yes
and
you said it took quite a while for you
to excavate that area correct
yes in fact you said that you had to go
back two different times it took you
several hours correct
no we or we went back to the burn pit
one additional time
two times total two times total and then
several hours each time correct
that's correct let's bring in dina and
terry to discuss dixon defense one last
time
dina the defense argued dixon a drug
addict believed it was reasonable to
burn and discard a body
does that help the defense in any way
i don't think it does because it's not
reasonable
and so it doesn't necessarily matter
that whether or not he was a drug addict
or not
it's similar maybe to say you know he
wouldn't have hit that car
if he hadn't been on drugs you know at
the end of the day
you you can't burn the body and it's not
a defense under the law
that he may have done it anyway because
he was either on drugs
or perpetually on drugs he no longer
thought the fact is it was
not reasonable and it's not a valid
defense yeah i think a lot of people
myself through my clients
uh know a lot of drug addicts not all of
them are burying bodies and burning them
so i don't know if it's gonna work
and then terry kind of with that could a
poor explanation of
why the body was disposed um end up
hurting dixon in the long run when
trying to beat that top charge of murder
brian you know honestly it's never easy
to explain to a jury
why you you know cut up a body put it in
a burn pit
and try to burn up the remains it
clearly
is a consciousness of guilt and any
explanation i think is going to
backfire and the jury's probably going
to think this was a cold-blooded murder
this was not self-defense or
anything else like that because if it
had been
why would he be trying to destroy the
body
and get rid of all of the evidence so i
think whatever explanation he's trying
to give here
is not going to suffice and i do think
the jury is going to think
because you did all of this it must mean
that you are guilty of murder
yeah and and the law at least has this
charge called falsus and uno falsus and
omnibus basically
if you're false in one thing you're
false in everything and so
that may kind of hurt the defense here
even if that charge is not there
that concept still works really well
dina
terry i want to thank you very much for
joining us today and contributing
and i want to thank you for joining us
here at the law and crime daily we'll
see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you